chile vive un nuevo momento crítico de
la pandemia que ha llevado al gobierno a
decretar la cuarentena total a partir de
este sábado en toda la región
metropolitana en la que viven 8 millones
de los 19 millones de chilenos será la
tercera vez en toda la pandemia que la
región metropolitana entre en una
cuarentena total esto se produce ante la
alza sostenida en el número de casos que
se ha visto en los últimos días y que ha
llevado a un colapso del sistema
hospitalario saturado en un 96 por
ciento a nivel país pero con una cifra
que alcanza el 98 y el 99 en el caso de
la región metropolitana donde desde hace
días se sabe que no hay más de una
treintena de camas disponibles para toda
la región este viernes veíamos como
algunos hospitales decidían cerrar sus
puertas y no admitir a más pacientes
mientras que los pacientes menos graves
están siendo tratados al ahora en
centros médicos barriales esto ante el
ritmo de vacunación que continúa en el
país pero a una menor velocidad que lo
que veíamos en un comienzo sin embargo
ya se ha alcanzado el 75% de la
población objetiva que ha sido vacunada
con una dosis mientras que el 58 5% de
la población objetivo de unos 15
millones de personas ya ha sido vacunada
con dos dosis el llamado de las
autoridades es que aquellos jóvenes que
no han acudido a vacunarse cuando le
correspondía por su calendario lo hagan
hay más de 900 mil rezagados recordando
que más de un 80% de las personas que
están en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos no completaron su esquema de
inoculación la sutiss registrará además
tres veces más población menor de 50
años que lo que se produjo en la primera
ola